c
vous savez où nous sommes
alors nous sommes sur le nst eaux de la
rivière langevin dit le n est ce cap
blanc donc qui débute à 550 mètres
d'altitude et qui mène jusqu'à 2000
mètres là dessus c'est un sentier qui
mène jusqu'à la plaine des sables et qui
fait une superficie totale de 460
hectares donc sur ce site là c'est la
fédération départementale de pêche qui
en est le gestionnaire et nous en tant
que geste gestionnaires on est amené à
faire un entretien notamment des berges
éliminer les plantes exotiques
envahissantes nous on est une équipe sur
le terrain avec un chef d'equipe qui va
encadrer aussi l'équipe sur le terrain
et on va éliminer bien souvent de
manière manuelle ces espèces exotiques
envahissantes pour remettre en valeur
des espèces indigènes et endémiques et
une fois qu'on aura à éliminer un
maximum de ces espèces exotiques là on
va remettre en valeur le parcours de
pêche pour permettre aux usagers de
découvrir le site vraiment sous ses plus
belles plus bel aspect
alors une part intégrante de mon métier
c'est de faire découvrir au public
l'espace naturel sensible de cap blanc
via des visites guidées sur la journée
ou sur la matinée donc le but c'est de
découvrir un maximum d'espèces que ce
soit au niveau de la flore et de la
faune the doors concerne les espèces
indigènes et endémiques
j'ai assez visible là j'emmène des gens
découvrir un peu les richesses de notre
forêt il a notamment là je m'appuie sur
un bois grand barca trois appellations
doit de remparts boîte galles ou boîtes
belle merde un mois de retard parce
qu'il pousse souvent à flandres en par
watt galles parce qu'on s'en servaient
en application notamment chez des
cochons pour traiter la galerie et boîte
belle merde parce que c'est une espèce
toxiques
ça c'est le côté un peu humoristique ça
fait souvent rire les gens on l'appelle
boîte belle mère c'est une plante
vraiment mortel faut surtout pas la
consommer en tisane faire très attention
cette plante est vraiment très toxiques
d'où l'appellation aussi de bois de
belle mère ou bois de rend pas il faut
savoir que en ce qui concerne les
espèces indigènes et endémiques ou
exotiques donc exotiques sont les
plantes qui ont été apportées par
l'homme elles ont tout ce qu'on appelle
des queues de détermination donc des
principes pour apprendre à connaître ces
espèces là les botanistes quand ils vont
identifier une espèce ils vont passer
par ce qu'on appelle des que
détermination donc ils vont regarder la
forme des feuilles savoir si la feuille
et simple ou composé donc une feuille
simple par exemple là on peut prendre
l'exemple du goyavier le voyage glisser
une feuille simple elle est formée d'une
seule feuille alors qu'il ya des plantes
dites apple composer
c'est d'en trouver un exemple parlant de
prendre la montrerai tout à l'heure le
l'exemple du faux poivrier sur la même
feuille il va y avoir plusieurs folioles
donc ça c'est une plante dit apple
composer mais elle est composée de
plusieurs podiums la feuille en elle
même c'est une feuille avec plusieurs
portions de podium il ya la disposition
des feuilles qui va jouer aussi sur la
tige dont les feuilles peuvent être face
à face on va dire qu'elles sont opposées
elles peuvent être une à une sur la tige
on va dire qu'elles sont alternés ou en
couronne autour d'un même de faire tirer
il ya plein de petits principe comme ça
pour apprendre à identifier les espèces
souvent les gens ont dit ouais mais on
dirait la même plante celle ci est celle
d'à côté on dire exactement la même
mais si on est à suffisamment attentif
on peut se rendre compte que des petits
critères qui vont permettre de
l'identifier par exemple à on a celle ci
le bois de corail une très belle
appellation la belle boîte bourail donc
tout simplement par rapport à son
inflorescence c'est vrai que là c'est
pas spécifiquement remarquable mais en
période de floraison devait faire une
fleur tout ramifié blanche qu'on compare
à l'animal marin le corail et les
feuilles on voit qu'elles sont disposées
elles sont opposés donc les feuilles
sont face à face ça c'est aussi une
belle détermination de l'espace et à
l'eau si c'est une plante toxique pour
faire attention
après en ce qui concerne la flore la
faune pardon mais qu'on essaie surtout
en ce qui concerne les oiseaux on a des
espèces indigènes et endémiques on a le
texte est l'oiseau blanc le l'oiseau la
vierge donc c'est des oiseaux souvent
qu'ils sont très curieux quand on est
dans les sentiers si on est suffisamment
observateurs on va les voir ils vont
venir à proximité de nous ils vont nous
observer voir ce qui se passe et
certains les appellent souvent pour les
cta cloisons coulon parce qu'à l'époque
ils se faisaient capturer très
facilement parce que justement il venait
face est un peu proximité des gens et
les gens les attraper facilement mais je
n'ai pas si couillon que ça en fait
c'est en marchant dans les sentiers nous
on va on va remuer les herbes on va
marcher au sol faire du mouvement ça va
faire lever les insectes et souvent il a
tendance à nous suivre pour picorer les
insectes qui vont se dés collés sur
notre passage alors le paille-en-queue
aussi c'est l'oiseau emblématique de la
réunion sous notamment sur
le ms on a la chance d'avoir énormément
de couple qu'on voit souvent voler à une
altitude relativement haute mais on a la
possibilité notamment dans ce sentier là
ce petit sentier d'interprétation
on a un couple qui vient tous les ans
niché à moins d'un mètre du sol
donc ça c'est un aspect qu'on a la
possibilité à d'offrir aux visiteurs de
passage notamment scolaires elles on
peut citer de voir cet oiseau là de
relativement près en respectant
justement la nidification parce que vous
pas faire n'importe quoi surtout pas
déranger l'animal dans son nid donc on y
va très discrètement un par un pour
l'observer et on se rend compte qu'on le
dérange pas plus que ça parce que tous
les ans il revient niché au même endroit
et on a la chance de présenter chaque
année au grand public